Football Leaks, filtre du Football Leaks, Title Football Leaks, Footballer Leaks, Website, die schnüffelt Football Leaks, ein Website, die schnüffelt, ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit. Heute sprechen wir im Rasenfunk über ein Thema, das um die Welt ging, nämlich die Football Leaks, ein euch sicherlich nicht ganz neues Thema, denn es hat auch schon im Rasenfunk stattgefunden, es gibt dazu schon einen Kurzpass und ein Tribünengespräch und nun aus aktuellem Anlass ein zweites Tribünengespräch. Und ich freue mich, dass wiederum Rafael Buschmann, einer der Autoren der Football Leaks und derjenige, der diesen Datenschatz in Händen hält oder hielt zumindest als Erster, wieder die Zeit sich genommen hat, um mit mir darüber zu sprechen. Hallo Rafael.
Ich freue mich selber, die Einladung.
Ja, ich freue mich auch, dass dieses Thema konstant ein bisschen im Rasenfunk stattfindet, denn es ist notwendig. Wir werden gleich mal ein bisschen darüber sprechen, was der aktuelle Anlass ist. Vorher geht noch ein Dank raus. Wenn wir jetzt so viel über schmutzige Fußballgeschäfte sprechen und Sponsorengelder, möchte ich dann doch an der Stelle kurz darauf hinweisen, der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsor-frei. Und zwar wegen Rasenfunk-Supportern wie Nils B. Christian K. Krausi, Steffen und Timo. Herzlichen Dank. Ihr alle unterstützt uns. Wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen tun. Aber nun, weg vom Kommerz und hinein in die sehr saubere Welt des Fußballs. Rafael, ich vermute, du hast die Frage schon so aufgestellt bekommen, dass ich es jetzt auch an der Stelle noch mal tun kann, ohne dass wir es vorher abgesprochen hätten. Fasse mal noch mal kurz zusammen, was sind denn eigentlich die Football Leaks, falls es jemand doch nicht mitbekommen hat?
Also die Football Leaks, zunächst einmal habe ich immer noch eine Gänsehaut von diesen Einspielern, die du da am Anfang hattest, weil das in der Nachbetrachtung immer wieder einen so ein bisschen durchschüttelt, wenn man sich dann ansieht, wie sehr diese Nachrichten auch um die Welt gegangen sind oder immer noch um die Welt gehen und an unterschiedlichen Orten besprochen werden. Die Football Leaks, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, sind entstanden aus einer Website, die im Herbst 2015 gelauncht wurde von einem jungen Portugiesen und seinem Team. Das Team kennen wir nicht. Wir kennen John, diesen Portugiesen, mit dem wir uns mittlerweile nach zahlreichen Versuchen der Anwarnung irgendwann im Jahr 2016 das erste Mal getroffen haben und der uns seitdem immer wieder Dokumente aus dem Innersten des Fußballs übergeben hat. Mittlerweile deutlich über 20 Millionen Dokumente. Das ist ein riesiges Volumen, ein riesiger Datenschatz, der die unterschiedlichsten Spieler, Vereine, funktionäre Agenten, Verbände immer wieder ausleuchtet bzw. dort hinein leuchtet, wo die jeweiligen Player des Fußballs vielleicht ungern den Scheinwerfer hin haben möchten, weil dieser Scheinwerfer dann auch auf Dinge leuchtet, die oftmals im Graubereich sind, teilweise im illegalen Bereich sich befinden, aber die Sachen, die wir beschreiben, sind fast immer. Dann stehen auch für Probleme, die es im Fußball gibt, für die Entkoppelung dieses Sports von dem, was er einst war, einem Volkssport, und jetzt mittlerweile tatsächlich ein Sport geworden ist für diejenigen, die sich ihn noch leisten können. Und die damit auch, also mit diesem Sport auch nichts anderes tun, als dauerhaft versuchen, ihre Profite auch noch zu maximieren. Und auf die Leute, auf diesen Bereich des Fußballs, gucken wir intensiv seit jetzt knapp zweieinhalb Jahren.
Genau, und diese Football Leaks Daten enthalten Verträge, E-Mails, offenbar auch zum Teil WhatsApp oder Chat-Nachrichten, zumindest zitierte daraus in eurem Buch. Also es ist ein Blick auch in sensible Datenbestände, wo man auch, und da werden sicherlich auch noch Fragen gleich zukommen, auch die Frage nach dem, woher kommt denn diese Daten stellen muss. Aber es ist eben ein sehr, sehr, sehr intimer Blick in die Fußballwelt, das kann man schon so sagen.
Absolut, es ist eine Offenlegung dieses, oft ja auch durch PR-Menschen und eine große Show drum herum, die auch Emotionalität basiert und auch für eine gewisse Verklärung sorgt. Also es ist ein Blick genau hinter diese Fassade, unter dieser Verklärungsfassade und hinter dieser Emotionalisierung des Sports, bei dem man dann auch irgendwann mal möglicherweise die eigene Rationalität ausblendet, weil man sich in aller erster Linie natürlich mit den eigenen Spielern vereint identifiziert. Und da versuchen wir, da versuchen wir ein gewisses Gegengewicht zu erzeugen mit den Dokumenten und einen solchen tiefen Einblick in die tatsächlichen Machenschaften des Fußballs und den Umgang des Fußballs mit sich selbst und mit seinen Fans. Ich glaube, den hat es so noch nie gegeben.
Ne, definitiv nicht. Und du warst eben derjenige, der zuerst Kontakt zu den Football Leaks machen hatte, insofern, dass du dann auch da einen fortwährenden Kontakt daraus machen konntest und euch eben diese Daten dann übergeben wurde. Die haben sich dann an euch gewandt. Das heißt, du hattest als erster auch ein bisschen Einblick in diese Welt. Wie hat es denn eigentlich dein Verhältnis zum Fußball verändert und zu den Vereinen und Personen, mit denen du dich emotional identifizierst?
Also ich arbeite jetzt im Fußball seit, als Journalist in dieser Fußball-Branche seit fast zwölf Jahren, seit 2006. Also in diesem Bereich. Es war auch schon vor footpolic so, dass es mir oftmals schwerfiel, dem Fußball diese Glaubwürdigkeit zuzugestehen, dem ihm ein normaler Fan zugesteht. Je professioneller man sich mit dieser Branche beschäftigt, desto stärker sieht man, wie viele Probleme sie eigentlich hat und welche Probleme auch im Hintergrund dort stattfinden. Seit den Football Leaks ist für mich aus vielen, was ich in den letzten Jahren geahnt habe, eine enorme Gewissheit geworden. Ich habe verstanden, dass die Fußballbranche nicht für sich alleine steht, sondern dass sie natürlich auch so in einer gewissen Schutzfunktion durch Journalisten, durch die Politik hofiert wird. Dass es im Prinzip im Fußball überhaupt niemanden mehr gibt, der wirklich eine Form von Kontrollinstanz bildet, weder die Justiz noch die Politik noch der Journalismus. Dadurch hat der Fußball auch so eine Form von Eigenleben entfaltet, wenn man sich die ganzen Verträge anschaut und sieht, wie auch ganz bewusst mit Vertragsklauseln versucht wird, die Öffentlichkeit beispielsweise zu belügen, in die Irre zu führen. Wie PR-Spindoktoren versuchen, ihre Nachrichten zu lancieren, das sehen wir ja teilweise aus den E-Mails, in denen dann auch drin steht, wer mit welchem Journalisten dann küngeln soll, um eine Nachricht zu...
Genau, und Spindoktoren sind eben Experten für PR, die versuchen, eine öffentliche Wahrnehmung zu drehen, indem sie dem eben einen anderen Spin geben, daher der Name.
Vollkommen richtig, man kennt sie aus der Politik, gerade im US-Wahlkampf, der kommt ohne Spindoktoren nicht mehr aus. Wenn man sich jetzt, um ein sehr aktuelles Beispiel zu nehmen in Deutschland, die Schulz-Story anguckt, dann sieht man, dass auch Spindoktoren in der Heathing-Politik sehr, sehr extremen Einschluss haben. Und im Fußball sind sie oftmals die Menschen, die in der dritten oder vierten Reihe stehen, aber eine extreme Bedeutung haben, wenn man den Sport tatsächlich verstehen möchte. Also wenn man verstehen möchte, wie jemand positioniert wird, warum er so positioniert wird, dann muss man sich anschauen, wie Spindoktoren funktionieren. Und das ist etwas, wofür wir die Football Leaks auch sehr gut einsetzen können, weil sie uns so die Möglichkeit geben, diese Fassade der Spindoktoren herunterzuweisen und eben dann auch festzustellen, warum bestimmte Spieler, bestimmte Aussagen tätigen, warum Vereine sich so oder anders verhalten. Und wir danach auch sagen können, hier gab es eine irre Führung, hier gab es eine Lüge, hier wurde bewusst getäuscht.
Genau, und von diesen Täuschungen gibt es nicht zu wenige im Fußballgeschäft. Das ganze…
Das ganze Buch ist voll davon, ja.
Ja, also irgendwann verliert man dann auch so ein bisschen die Relationen. Also mir ist beim Lesen aufgefallen, dass man liest ja immer von so großen Summen, dass man sich dann irgendwann denkt, was der verdient nur 12 Millionen im Jahr. Und da muss man sich kurz überlegen, Moment mal, was heißt das? Was würde das eigentlich für mich bedeuten, wenn ich das in einem Monat mal bekäme? Dann bräuchte ich den Rasfunk-Support. Das klappt nicht, unter anderem.
Aber ja, es gab aber auch, es gab nur das ganz kurz, um diese Relationen herzustellen. Es gab für mich aber auch so Punkte in dieser ganzen Football Leaks Berichterstattung, die mich dann auch nachhaltig echt erschüttert haben. Also wir haben mal über den Vertrag von Lionel Messi geschrieben und haben geschrieben, dass er mittlerweile pro Jahr auf rund 120 Millionen kommen kann. Eine Summe, die, also Jahresgehalt, eine Summe, die so absurd hoch ist für einen einzelnen Fußballer in einer Mannschaftssportart, dass wir angefangen haben, uns diese Summe auseinander zu dröseln, um zu gucken, wie sie eigentlich entsteht, aus welchen Blöcken und welche Klausen dort zusammenspielen. Und wenn man dann irgendwann an den Punkt kommt, dass man feststellt, dass der FC Barcelona für Lionel Messi dafür entschädigt, dass er eine Steuerhinterziehung begangen hat und ihm an der Stelle diese Strafe, die er gegenüber den Behörden bezahlen musste, über das normale Gehalt zurückgibt, indem sie bestimmte Vertragsdetails so verändert, dass genau dieser Bestandteil, den er damals als Strafe bezahlt hat, jetzt in sein normales, jährliches Gehalt einfließt. Und wenn man dann überlegt, dass der FC Barcelona seit 20 Jahren vom spanischen Staat mit Steuergeldern subventioniert wurde und dann feststellt, dass der steuerlich subventionierte FC Barcelona den Steuersünder Lionel Messi sein Steuervergehen zurückzahlt, dann muss man das einmal sacken lassen und sich im besten Fall nochmal ein paar Minuten einen Spaziergang ums Haus machen, um das zu kapieren. Denn mehr Zynismus, mehr Absurdität in diesem Fußballgeschäft als mit einem solchen Vertrag, möchte man meinen, geht gar nicht. Und dann lesen wir die nächsten Sachen und sehen die nächsten Dokumente und stellen fest, offenbar gibt es zu allem, was wir bislang gelesen haben, immer nochmal eine weitere Steigerung.
Wahnsinn. Und da kann man auch sehr gut den Unterschied zwischen Außendarstellung und tatsächlicher Innenwahrnehmung erklären. Messe in Club ist ja das Motto von Barcelona. Man hatte früher keinen Trikot-Sponsor, das ist jetzt schon weg. Und dass man so ein besonderer Club sei, in vielerlei Hinsicht eben auch im moralischen, ethischen Ding. Ja, das ist schwierig. Vermutlich dann doch nur einer von vielen Fußballvereinen inzwischen. Es gibt auch einen konkreten Anlass, warum wir zwar jetzt miteinander sprechen. Und zwar, weil ihr eine aktualisierte Taschenbuchversion von Football Leaks herausgegeben habt zu einem sehr, sehr fairen Preis, dass auch jeder, der vielleicht bisher sich das Buch noch nicht geholt hat, da mal reingucken kann. Was ist denn neu an dieser neuen Version?
Also wir haben in dieser neuen Version knapp über 50 Seiten hinzugefügt. Das sind vier neue Kapitel. Zwei Kapitel beschäftigen sich zum einen mit der Fortschreibung der Geschichte rund um unseren Whistleblower, um John und auch mit den Konsequenzen, die nach den Football Leaks entstanden sind, also sowohl den juristischen Konsequenzen als auch den Konsequenzen, die in der Branche selbst entstanden sind. Die anderen beiden Kapitel beschäftigen sich in erster Linie mit dem seit dem vergangenen Sommer völlig explodierten Transfermarkt. Also wir dröseln noch einmal das Sommer-Transferfenster 2017 auf und zeigen, wie die Absprachen zwischen PSG und Neymar abgelaufen sind, mit welchen Mitteln der FC Barcelona versucht hat, Spieler wie Coutinho loszueisen, welche Widerstände es dazu gab, wie die normalen Regeln in der Branche ausgehebelt werden, wenn ein Verein unbedingt einen Spieler braucht, wie diese 222 Millionen Kataris diese Branche geflutet haben und was aus diesem Geld oder mit diesem Geld passiert, welche Auswirkungen dieses Geld hat. Wir beschreiben unter anderem auch diesen völlig absurden Leihvertrag zwischen Paris Saint-Germain und dem Als-Monaco in Bezug auf un papier, bei dem man eben sehen kann, dass es nicht nur eine Seite gibt, die Schmoo betreibt im Fußball, sondern dass da einfach mehrere Seiten mit dazu gehören. Ein Leihvertrag, bei dem PSG im ersten Jahr nicht einen einzigen Cent an den Als-Monaco überweisen muss, den Spieler aber bekommt, mit der weiterführenden Absprache, dass man das Jahr darauf, den gesamten Betrag von, ich glaube es sind 145 Millionen, dann an Als-Monaco überweist. Man sieht, welche Hebe benutzt werden, um das Financial Fair Play zu umgeben, wie die Vereine sich absprechen, also all das, was in der freien Wirtschaft eigentlich dann auch irgendwann mal von einem Kartellamt untersucht werden würde oder von Herrn Justiz untersucht werden würde, ist halt im Fußball völlig gang und gäbe und läuft nach den eigenen Gesetzmäßigkeiten dieses Sports, ohne dass da eine äußere Grenze stattfinden könnte. In einem weiteren Kapitel des Buchs beschreiben wir dann die Auswirkungen der fast neun Milliarden, die die Premier League einspielt durch die TV-Gelder und wie dieses Geld sich auf die Transferaktivitäten der Premier League auswirken. Unter anderem zeigen wir dann auch auf, wie Arsenal Aubameyang verpflichtet hat, welchen Loyalty-Bonus, dass er am Ende seine Unterschrift. Auch unter diesen Vertrag setzt, bzw. dann auch den Vertrag bei Arsenal erfüllt oder in London erfüllt. Wir beschreiben, wie Liverpool investiert, der einstige Underdog-Club, der sich auch gerne so positionierte und mittlerweile aber genau in der gleichen Preiskategorie mitspielt, wie all die anderen Super-Clubs wie Chelsea, Manchester oder beide Manchesters. Das alles findet sich im neuen Buch.
Im Grunde kann man eigentlich sagen, wir sehen ja immer die Oberfläche und wenn man aber viele Dinge, die gerade passieren, gerade auch dieser gestiegene Transferwahnsinn, die immer größer werdenden Summen, auch die Höhenflüge und Absturz von Vereinen, die gefühlt extremer geworden sind in den letzten Jahren, wenn man das besser verstehen möchte, dann lohnt definitiv ein Blick in die Football Leaks. So manche Vermutung bestätigt sich da, aber man bekommt damit einfach einen anderen Blick, nämlich die Innsicht auf dieses Fußballbusiness und danach wundert einen eigentlich auch gar nichts mehr. Auch das, was man da in der Oberfläche sieht. Also so ein Leihvertrag mit Mbappé, das hat ja jeder Fußballfan auf der Welt gesehen, das war ein Vehikel, um das Financial Fair Play zu umgehen und dann kann man natürlich die völlig legitimen Anschlussfragen stellen. Wann wird da denn mal etwas dagegen getan, entweder von den Fußballverbänden selbst oder von der Politik? Aber dann noch mal zusätzliche Informationen dazu zu bekommen, wie lief das alles, woher kommt eigentlich all dieses katarische Geld, mit welchem Grund ist das eigentlich im Markt, über welche Größenordnung sprechen wir da? Da bekommt man gerade, finde ich, das komplettste Bild vor allem über die Football Leaks, weil ihr eben auch einfach auf Informationen zugreifen könnt, die ganz, ganz wenigen nur zugänglich sind. Was mich zu der Frage bringt, Rafael, ich weiß ja, dass das Terabytes an Daten sind, an Textdateien. Ich habe das jetzt nicht in Bibeln umgerechnet vorher. Ich vermute aber mal, es wären sehr, sehr viele Bibeln, die ihr lesen müsstet. Die Bibel ist ja quasi das literarische Saarland, wenn es um Größenvergleiche geht. Was würdest du denn sagen, bei wie viel Prozent steht ihr denn aktuell? Also wie viel habt ihr euch schon durchforsten können? Wie viel wird noch kommen aus dem aktuellen Datenbestand?
Eine Frage, die uns oft gestellt wird und die ich immer wieder damit auch beantworten muss, dass ich es schlicht und ergreifend nicht weiß. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass weil unsere Software in Teller, die wir nutzen, das ist ja Software, die eigentlich Profiler und Steuerfahnder benutzen, auch andere Formen von Privatdetektiven oder Ermittlern benutzen. Mit der arbeiten wir an den Football Leaks ebenfalls. Diese Software kann eine Sache nicht. Sie kann uns nicht sagen, wie viele Dateien wir am Ende tatsächlich durchforstet haben. Also sie kann uns das zwar in absoluten Zahlen sagen. Sie kann uns irgendwann sagen, ihr habt jetzt 70 Prozent aller Dokumente mal gesehen oder 50 Prozent aller Dokumente gesehen. Aber sie kann uns nicht sagen, ob wir alle Dokumente miteinander in Relation gesetzt haben. Das heißt, wenn ich beispielsweise das Firmenkonstrukt von Cristiano Ronaldo auseinander nehme und versuche, mir erklärbar zu machen, dann sehe ich dort immer nur einen Ausschnitt, weil ich nach bestimmten Themenfeldern suche in Teller. Ich suche nach Cristiano Ronaldo, ich suche nach seinem Firmen, ich suche nach seinem Steuerberater, nach seinem Verein, nach seiner Familie. Was ich aber dann im nächsten Schritt machen muss, ist im Prinzip nach jeder seiner Firmen singulär nochmal weiter suchen. Es kann sein, dass wir aktuell, wenn wir eine Geschichte machen, bei der wir feststellen, dass Cristiano Ronaldo nicht nur sein normales Offshore-Vehikel, über die wir schon geschrieben haben, benutzt, sondern auch nur für seine Hotels Offshore-Vehikel in Luxemburg und Jersey hat, dann stoßen wir da mehr oder minder durch Zufall drauf, weil sich dann aus dem Datensegment auf einmal noch eine neue Firma für uns sichtbar macht, bei der wir dann schauen müssen, wer sind die Strohmänner vor dieser Firma und wer ist eigentlich der wirtschaftlich Berechtigte. Wenn wir dann am Ende den Namen Cristiano Ronaldo finden, dann stellen wir diese Firma – im Prinzip fangen wir dann von neuem an – in Relation mit all dem, was wir vorher schon gefunden und gesehen haben. Deshalb kann es sein, selbst wenn wir 100 Prozent dieses Datensegments uns irgendwann angeguckt haben, dass wir immer noch kaum etwas wissen, weil wir viele Relationen noch nicht gefunden haben. Das ist mühselig. Ich bin wahnsinnig dafür dankbar, dass der Spiegel uns die Möglichkeit gibt, mit einem so großen und tollen Team jeden Tag daran zu arbeiten, weil auch das nicht selbstverständlich ist, dass man in der heutigen Zeit diese Ressourcen dafür bekommt, um sich so einwühlen zu können und auch Kollegen hat, die das mit so einem langen Atem machen. Man wühlt da teilweise in dem Zeug auch über Wochen und Monate und ist da echt für die Öffentlichkeit im Dunkeln, bevor man dann so ein bisschen den einen Goldnugget findet, der am Ende eine große Geschichte darstellt und auch uns hilft, dieses Fußballgeschäft transparenter zu machen. Aber dafür braucht es viel Durchhaltevermögen und eben auch Ressourcen, weil so etwas Gehalt kostet, weil so etwas Software kostet, weil so etwas Reisekapazitäten verschlingt. All diese Sachen müssen reproduziert werden und dafür braucht man einen Arbeitgeber, der dann auch sagt, wir gehen dieses Risiko ein und lassen euch genau das machen, weil es unser ureigenstes Interesse ist, investigative Geschichten als Spiegelhaus zu veröffentlicht.
Mensch, ich könnte dir jetzt noch 100 Fragen stellen, aber eigentlich soll das ja so ein bisschen eine Sendung der Hörerinnen und Hörer werden, die ja selbst unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de ihre Fragen gestellt haben. Deswegen zwinge ich mich jetzt zu den Hörerinnen- und Hörerfragen zu kommen. Und da gab es eine zum Beispiel von Sabi unter Strich 09, die würde gerne wissen, ob du das Gefühl hast, mit dem Buch als dem Thema als solchen genug in Anführungszeichen bewirkt zu haben, denn sie schreibt und das findet sich auch noch in einigen anderen Kommentaren wieder, dass es so scheint, als würde sich die Fußballblase einfach genauso weiterdrehen, als wäre nichts gewesen.
Also ich, seitdem ich als, oder in meiner Funktion als Investigativjournalist versuche, ich mich so weit wie möglich davon zu entfernen, mein eigenes Seelenheil davon abhängig zu machen, ob eine Geschichte Auswirkungen hat, ob sie fliegt, ob sie für Veränderungen sorgt.
Und das ist klasse, wenn man da so viel Zeit reinsteckt.
Also das ist dadurch, dass das ja so ein bisschen wie so ein eigenes Baby ist, wenn man so lange in so einem Projekt arbeitet, fällt das einem manchmal leichter und manchmal schwerer. Und natürlich würde ich gerne sehen, dass irgendwann mal die Verbände ihre Arschbacken zusammenkneifen und sagen, wir wollen das Ganze jetzt auf ein tragfähiges, wertestarkes, aus dem Fußballwerten entstehendes und vor allem dem Gesetzbuch entsprechendes Konstrukt stellen und möchten, dass der Fußball sauberer wird und daran arbeiten wir alle zusammen. Natürlich würde ich das gerne mal sehen, dass Verbände das tun, aber dafür bin ich vielleicht zu sehr realist und zu wenig Träumer, dass ich auch im Vorfeld wusste, dass das nicht passieren wird. Ich versuche auch meinem Team oder wenn wir im Team genau darüber reden, weil jeder auch manchmal schlechte Tage hat und dann einfach sagt, so eine Scheiße, hier passiert doch gar nichts oder es geht nicht weiter, dass man dann versucht, auch Relation zu anderen großen Enthüllungen herzustellen. Was ist denn nach dem NSA-Komplex, nach Snowden tatsächlich passiert? Wir alle nutzen weiterhin unsere Smartphones und liefern unsere Daten den großen Unternehmen und zwar for free. Was ist aus den großen Abgas-Skandalen geworden? Ich sehe jetzt nicht zwingend, dass weniger Autos gefahren werden. Also ich könnte damit ohne Ende im Prinzip, könnte ich das fortführen. Wikileaks könnten wir anführen und uns ansehen, wie viele unterschiedliche Problemfelder dort aufgedeckt wurden und wie wenig am Ende an klaren, direkten Veränderungen stattgefunden haben. Und trotzdem glaube ich, muss man sich auch ansehen, was Football Leaks am Ende erreicht hat. Wenn wir gucken, dass mittlerweile drei Dutzend große Verfahren angestoßen werden, mittlerweile abgeschlossen sind, dass Millionen Gelder in die Steuerkassen gerade zurückfließen, weil es bestimmte Deals wie bei Di Maria oder bei Cavahall oder Marcello gibt. Also wirklich große Fußballer, große Namen, jetzt Mourinho als prominente Figur, die alle hohe 6-stellige oder 7-stellige Beträge zurückzahlen, weil sie durch die Football Leaks mit ihren Steuersünden aufgeflogen sind. Und wir befinden uns gerade erst ein Jahr nachdem tatsächlich unsere Berichterstattung Wucht bekommen hat. Wir haben im Dezember 2016 unsere Veröffentlichung platziert. Dann haben wir gesehen, dass so ab Februar, März die großen Ermittlungen begonnen haben. Wir sehen jetzt, dass einige der – in Anführungsstrichen – kleineren Vergehen so weit abgeschlossen sind, indem die Staaten Deals mit den jeweiligen Spielern gefunden haben und Nachzahlungen stattgefunden haben. Das kann man mögen oder nicht. Ich bin kein Freund davon, dass sich Superreiche freikaufen können, sondern ich glaube, dass jeder, der ein steuerliches Vergehen dieser Größenordnung getan hat, sich am Ende in einen ordentlichen Prozess dazu erklären muss. Aber das ist etwas, was die Justiz am Ende entscheiden muss. Da bin ich als Journalist nicht in der Lage, das großartig zu kritisieren. Das ist die Entscheidung eines jeden Staates. Ich kann am Ende dazu Kommentare schreiben oder erklären, wie ich es aufgrund der jeweiligen Gesetzmäßigkeiten sehe. Nichtsdestotrotz bewerte ich das erst einmal nur aus der Sicht, was wirklich passiert ist. Passiert sind diese horrenden Millionensummen, die zurückgeflossen sind und weitere Prozesse oder Ermittlungsverfahren, die angestoßen wurden. Wir haben jetzt vor ein paar Wochen über ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Jorge Mendez geschrieben, das in Portugal losgetreten wurde von der Steuerverhandlung und an dem mittlerweile zahlreiche weitere europäische Ermittlungsbehörden teilnehmen. Dort geht es um zwei Jahre, die Steuerbehörden ermitteln zwei Jahre aus, in denen Jorge Mendez Transfers getätigt hat. Sie schauen sich alle seine Transfers aus diesem Zeitfenster an und sie haben festgestellt, dass der Spielerberater Jorge Mendez in diesem Zeitraum einen Umsatz mit Transfers erzielt hat von 1, 3 Milliarden. Nicht Millionen, Milliarden. Dieses Geld wird jetzt durchleuchtet, diese Geldflüsse werden durchleuchtet. Es wird geschaut, ob darauf alle Steuern bezahlt wurden, welche Handgelder ausgespielt wurden, welche Summen ansonsten noch aufgewendet wurden, um einen solchen Transfer zu stemmen, um es vorsichtig zu formulieren. Ich glaube, dass diese Form von Ermittlungsverfahren Jahre dauern werden. Wenn wir da einen Vergleichswert nehmen, wir haben mit dem Spiegel 2015 das Sommermärchen enthüllt, die Geldflüsse rund um das Sommermärchen des DFW. Wir haben jetzt das Jahr 2018 und die Justiz ist jetzt so weit, dass sie eine Anklage abschließt. Das heißt, es hat mindestens drei Jahre gedauert bei einem relativ übersichtlichen Teilnehmerfeld und bei einem Geldfluss, der singulär war und schon fast bis zum Ende auserzählt war oder bis zu einem Punkt auserzählt war, und zwar bis zu dem Fluss nach Katar. Und trotzdem dauert es nahezu drei Jahre, bis die Justiz dort auch mal in den Zielsektor Prozesseröffnung kommen kann oder Anklagerhebung kommen kann. Und wenn man sich dann ansieht, wie bei den Football Leaks, wie viele unterschiedliche Geldflüsse, wie komplizierte Geldflüsse sind, wie viele einzelne Player in diesem Geschäft von uns dann auch offengelegt wurden. Wir haben ein riesiges Spielerberaterkarussell aufgedeckt, das in Argentinien beginnt und mit Strohmännern in Europa hantiert, bei denen Strohmänner dann einen minimalen Prozentsatz aus, also eigentlich einen Promillesatz aus einem Transfer abgrasen, das sind manchmal nur 2000 Euro oder 1500 Euro. Dafür aber die große Summe, die sie entgegennehmen, weiterleiten an Firmen auf den British Virgin Islands, nach Hongkong, Dubai, wie auch immer.
Was es ja auch den Vereinen total schwer macht, wenn du im Hintergrund jedes Beraters oder desjenigen, der mitkommt zur Vertragsunterzeichnung, überprüfen müsstest, ohne den Zugriff auf diese Football-Leaks-Daten zu haben. Wie soll man da auch noch erkennen, dass da andere Leute dahinter stehen?
Absolut. Wobei die in Wahrheit spielen, die Vereine dieses Spiel ja auch maßgeblich mit. Weil wenn ein Berater einen gesamten Verhandlungsprozess alleine gestaltet und mit dem Verein verhandelt, mit dem Spieler verhandelt, möglicherweise mit den Eltern verhandelt und am Ende zur Vertragsunterschrift ein völlig anderer Mensch kommt, der dann, bei dem es dann heißt, der wird von der Firma entsandt und soll einfach nur die Verträge unterzeichnen. Spätestens an der Stelle müsste normalerweise auch ein Verein einmal kurz aufhorchen und vielleicht eine Due-Diligence-Prüfung bei einem solchen Berater durchführen, um zu schauen, was ist eigentlich sein Background, warum darf der jetzt eine zweistellige Millionensumme auf seinem Konto entgegennehmen, obwohl wir von diesen Menschen vorher noch nie was gehört haben. Wir hatten ja diesen völlig absurden Fall, dass wir in Holland einen ehemaligen Dichter gefunden haben, also einen Dichter, der früher relativ prominent war in Holland, danach aber ziemlich abgestürzt ist, weil er mit seinem Schreiben nicht mehr den Erfolg hatte, den er sich mal aufgebaut hatte und der dann von jemandem angesprochen wurde, der ihm gesagt hat, Zulu, du kannst relativ einfaches Geld machen, wenn du mit einem Koffer zu einem Flugplatz fährst, diese Verträge dort übergibst und die Verträge, die dir hingehalten werden, auch noch unterschreibst. Und der hat uns das dann genau erklärt, dieser holländische Dichter, der uns dann erklärt hat, wie er auf ein Rollfeld in Italien fährt, dort ein Privatflugzeug landet, es kommen sechs Leute raus, es werden zwei Koffer geöffnet, dann wird einmal unterschrieben, die Koffer werden ausgetauscht, dann werden Summen überwiesen, er bekommt seinen Promillesatz davon, der Rest des Geldes geht eben auf die British Virgin Islands oder auf eine der anderen Steueroasen und damit ist er raus. Er sagte dann die ganze Zeit, wieso, ich habe doch einfach nur dieses bisschen Geld da quasi entgegengenommen, weil ich da hingefahren bin. Nein, du hast einen Vertrag unterschrieben und du bist derjenige, der zur Hechenschaft gezogen wird, am Ende von der Politik, von der Justiz, wie auch immer. Und von diesen Modellen, von diesen Strommännern, die platziert werden vor die jeweiligen großen Berater, die dann die Multimillionensummen abkassieren, davon gibt es Dutzende. Wir haben so viele davon gefunden, dass wir am Ende, wir hätten mit diesem Organigramm, glaube ich, eine ganze Hauswand pflastern können, um einfach zu sehen, wie dieses Geldkarussell tatsächlich abläuft und wie Steuergelder in massiver Form aus Europa entzogen werden und Menschen zugeführt werden, die sich völlig im Hintergrund verhalten, ohne dass man sie am Ende dafür möglicherweise auch zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann. Mittlerweile ist in Frankreich ein großes Verfahren auch gegen diesen Beraterring eröffnet worden. Wir werden sehen, wo es endet. Aber das sind sehr komplizierte Fälle, die wir beschreiben, weil auch die wirtschaftliche Situation im Fußball eine sehr komplizierte ist. Das ist möglich mit vielen Firmen, mit vielen Firmenkonstrukten, die so ein bisschen Matryoshka-artig funktionieren, dass man eine Puppe in die andere setzt oder eine Firma in die andere setzt und so verschachtelt, dass am Ende jeder Fahnder, jeder Verband nahezu die Kontrolle darüber verliert, wie der Geldfluss tatsächlich rund um einen Transfer stattfindet.
Und das ist jetzt die eine Seite, so ein bisschen was hat das bei der Justiz bewirkt, hast du jetzt ja schon ein paar Beispiele genannt. Es gibt ja aber auch noch eine andere Seite und da hat Saure Hefe 1887 einen sehr ehrlichen, wie ich finde, Kommentar dazu geschrieben. Ich lese ihn mal vor. Er schreibt, ich würde mich als sehr fußballinteressierten Menschen beschreiben. Ich lese täglich irgendwelche Artikel auf verschiedensten Webseiten, gucke Spiele aus verschiedenen Ligen und bin auch ab und an bei meinem Verein, natürlich im HSV, im Stadion. Trotzdem ist Football Leaks bis auf zwei, drei in Anführungszeichen Bomben am Anfang, er nennt dann Ronaldo, Özil etc. komplett an mir vorbeigegangen. Klar, ab und an kam vom Spiegel auch was zum HSV, aber wenn man ein bis zwei Leute im Verein kennt, steht da nichts drin, was man nicht eh schon wusste. Bin ich zu naiv oder sollte ich mich informieren? Welche Gründe gibt es für mich, das Buch zu lesen? Oder ist es einfach so wie Max, also jetzt in dem Fall ich, letztens mit Samer und Henkel im Tribünengespräch besprach, dass der Fußball halt einfach nicht wichtig genug ist im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Themen und ich deswegen nicht alles an mich heran lasse, um mir nicht auch noch dieses Hobby kaputt zu machen. Wie gehst du mit solchen Gedanken um?
Zum einen werde ich niemandem, niemandem mein Buch ans Herz legen, der in irgendeiner Form sich dieses Hobby bewahren möchte oder sonst was. Ich bin nicht die Maren Gilzer, der versucht, dieses Buch an den Mann zu bringen. Jeder, der interessiert ist, kann es lesen. Ansonsten feel free, das Leben auch so zu gestalten. Ich glaube grundsätzlich, dass der Fußball absolut wichtig genug ist, um genau diese Bewertung vorzunehmen und sich tiefer mit dieser Materie auseinanderzusetzen. Ich glaube, dass der Fußball aber eine andere Stärke hat, die es ermöglicht, diese Einblicke vielleicht nicht so wahrzunehmen. Und das ist der Fußball emotionalisiert. Der Fußball schafft es, dass man eine Loyalität zu den jeweiligen Personen, Vereinen, über die wir schreiben, entwickelt. Und diese Loyalität, diese Emotionalität ist etwas, was sich kaum jemand in Wahrheit auch beschädigen lassen möchte. Und das sind vielleicht die Faktoren, die am ehesten dazu führen, dass der ein oder andere Fan sagt, lasst mich mit euren Enthüllungen in Ruhe. Ich will weiterhin am Samstag zumindest etwas Freude haben, wenn ich schon die ganze Woche mich mit irgendwelchen Themen herumplagen muss. Und das ist eine Haltung, die ich in Wahrheit dann auch hinnehme. Das ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Jeder soll am Ende sein Leben so ausgestalten, wie er möchte. Wir schreiben das Buch oder wir machen die Football Leaks für die Leute, die in den vergangenen Jahren eh schon das Gefühl hatten, dass sie nicht genau wissen, was in dieser Branche vorgeht. Und die vielleicht dann auch etwas kritischer gegenüber steigenden Ticketpreisen, steigenden Trikot-Preisen waren, die auch bei TV-Abos mittlerweile sagen, hey Leute, das geht zu weit, das geht nicht. Warum macht ihr das? Warum schröpft ihr und so? Und denen zeigen wir, warum der normale Fan geschröpft wird, weil wir ihnen eben offenlegen, wo die Gelder am Ende hingehen. Wir zeigen ihnen, wie der Kreislauf des Geldes im Fußball tatsächlich aussieht und wo die Finanzierung des normalen Fans landet. Sie landet eben nicht in erster Linie da unten bei dem ganz normalen Spieler, der sein Säckchen voll Geld mit nach Hause nimmt, sondern da gibt es einen richtigen Perifermarkt, der dahinter steckt. Es gibt auch bei den jeweiligen Spielern mittlerweile Größenordnungen, über die Fans aufgeklärt werden sollten oder ihnen offengelegt werden sollten. Das ist für mich die Kernaussage eines jeden investigativ arbeitenden Journalisten, der am Ende niemanden bekehren sollte. Das will ich nicht. Ich will einfach aufdecken und ich will enthüllen, wie der Fußball tatsächlich funktioniert. Ich will den Markt dahinter enthüllen. Ich will aufzeigen, welche Probleme dieser Markt hat und auch darauf hinweisen, dass ich glaube, dass wenn dieser Markt weiterhin an dieser Spirale in der Form dreht, dass er irgendwann seine Glaubwürdigkeit verlieren wird, weil wir ja auch in den Football Leaks andere Schattenseiten gezeigt haben, und zwar die Schattenseiten von Wettbetrug, von Einflussnahme Investoren auf Vereine, von Spielverschiebungen, von Kader-Zerflückungen, weil ein Investor eine Rendite an einem Spieler haben wollte. All diese Dinge ist ja das, was, das ist jetzt die Spitze des Eisbergs, aber je weiter der Markt in der Form überdreht, desto eher können solche Sachen auch zu Normalität werden. Und für die Leute, die ganz normal ins Stadion gehen und Spaß an diesem Sport haben, gerade die sollten ja ein gewisses Interesse daran haben zu erfahren, wohin sich der Fußball entwickelt und ob sie damit zurechtkommen. Ich glaube auch in der Tat nicht, dass das an so vielen Leuten vorbeigegangen ist, wie der Saure Hefe, genau wie Saure Hefe das beschreibt. Wir merken, wie groß die Reaktionen sind mittlerweile bei Twitter, bei Facebook, bei Instagram, bei unseren Lesungen, die sehr stark besucht werden. Ich glaube trotzdem aber auch, dass der Fußball ein solches Massenphänomen ist, das ihn ja auch seit Jahrzehnten auszeichnet, dass dort Menschen à la couleur hingehen. Der normale Handwerker bis zum Arzt, der Fußball ist völlig durchmischt und genauso ist natürlich auch die Interessenlage durchmischt. Ich glaube auch, dass das heute mit der rein kritischen Berichterstattung nicht zwingend immer ein Millionenpublikum erreicht wird. Das war auch nie unser Bestreben, sondern wir wollen es den ermöglichen, die sich da auch tiefer mit auseinandersetzen wollen und vielleicht am Ende unser Buch dann für sich auch noch mal gebraucht haben, um ja ihre Einordnung zu schaffen. Ich persönlich glaube auch nicht, dass der Endkunde – und das ist nun mal auch jeder Fußballfan, auch wenn Kunde mittlerweile ja schon fast ein Schimpfwort in der Fußballbranche geworden ist – der Endkunde ist nicht derjenige, der am Ende all die Probleme einer jeweiligen Branche regeln kann. Ich habe ja oft gehört, warum gehen dann noch so viele Leute ins Stadion oder warum gucken dann immer noch so viele Leute Fußball und wenn ich dann frage, warum kaufen immer noch so viele Leute den Diesel oder irgendwie das iPhone? Ich glaube einfach, das ist nicht möglich, dass der Endkunde das regelt. Derjenige, der das regeln kann, ist am Ende die Politik bzw. die Justiz. Das entsteht, wenn natürlich auch der Endkunde ein gewisses Empörungspotenzial mitbringt oder eben auch aufzeigt, dass er mit den jeweiligen, mit den jeweiligen Branchen, Systematiken nicht einverstanden ist. Das erhöht den Druck darauf. Aber wir sehen zum Beispiel auch, dass direkt nach den Football Leaks ist im EU-Parlament ein Untersuchungsausschuss gegründet worden. Es gab die FIFA und Spielerberater sind eingeladen worden, um über die Probleme im Fußball zu diskutieren. Also da ist ja auch, da kommt ja auch Bewegung hin, die am Ende dazu führen soll, dass bestimmte Gesetzeslücken geschlossen werden sollen, dass möglicherweise auch bestimmte Probleme, die in den letzten Jahren durch die Globalisierung, durch den horrenden Geldfluss im Fußball entstanden sind, in den nächsten Jahren behoben werden sollen. Und das ist etwas, was ich zumindest als ersten Schritt als gut und richtig beachte. Ich sage aber auch gleichzeitig zu jedem, der mich fragt, warum vielleicht noch nicht alle irgendwie davon infiziert sind, von Football Leaks infiziert sind, dass ich sage, zum einen wollen wir das nicht und zum anderen stehen wir auch noch aus meiner Sicht relativ am Anfang der Football Leaks Beschreibung. Also ich glaube, dass in den nächsten Jahren dazu noch deutlich mehr kommen wird, dass der Datensatz einfach noch sehr viel in sich birgt und dass wir peu à peu versuchen, uns mit dieser Branche weiter auseinanderzusetzen und dann werden wir irgendwann mal für uns vielleicht zwei Striche drunter machen und sagen, wo stehen wir eigentlich und wollen wir jetzt vielleicht doch wieder was anderes in unserem Leben machen und dann haben wir jetzt genug gezeigt und offenbart. Aber jetzt im Moment haben wir noch reichlich an Futter und können weiter in diesen riesigen Berg rumwühlen.
Was ja auch so ein bisschen nach der Quelle dieses Futters die Frage stellt. Dazu haben wir auch einige Fragen bekommen, unter anderem von Bayern Henry und auch Kloko haben gefragt, sie wollen wissen, wie es John, also dem Whistleblower, geht, wie lange er die Sache noch weiter machen möchte und ob er in konkreter Gefahr schwebt.
Wie es ihm geht, ist aus meiner Sicht schwierig zu beantworten. Er freut sich vollständiger Gesundheit und lebt in seiner Anonymität. Er ist aber weiterhin jemand, der on the run ist, wie er das immer sagt. Mehr oder weniger unterwegs auf der Flucht, wie man es auch beschreiben möchte. Er ist jemand, der nicht länger als zwei Tage an einem Ort verbringt, der sehr oft seine eigene Location wechselt, der in der Welt zu Hause ist. Ich habe ihn jetzt an so vielen unterschiedlichen Orten schon getroffen in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren. Ich kann die kaum noch zählen.
Aber wie schafft man es denn, wenn man so auf einer ziellosen Flucht ist – also er hat ja kein Ziel, sondern muss sich einfach nur bewegen – wie schafft man es dann, so etwas überhaupt noch zu organisieren, diese Datenströme zusammenzuhalten, die Daten aufzubereiten, die dann euch übergeben werden? Er muss ja digital eine Infrastruktur aufgebaut haben, damit er im Grunde am jeden Art der Welt das weiter machen kann.
Da ich ein technisches Wrack bin, kann ich dir diese Frage in der Form nicht beantworten. Ich kann den Computer an-
Ja oder anders gefragt, spricht das nicht besonders dafür, dass das Team hinter John sehr groß oder zumindest über sehr gute Infrastrukturen verfügen muss und er dann vielleicht nur eben der sichtbare Teil dieses Teams ist und deswegen halt auch im Grunde ohne non-stop durch die Welt reist, um da keine Spuren zu hinterlassen, weil die Organisation eines solchen Leaks, die stelle ich mir wahnsinnig komplex vor. Wenn ihr schon mit hochtechnologischer Software so viele Hürden überspringen musst, um diese Daten zu sichten.
Das Problem ist, dass wir uns hier in einem spekulativen Raum über meine Quelle befinden und ich da als Journalist immer so ein bisschen lange Finger bekomme, weil ich das, also zum einen möchte ich nicht darüber spekulieren, was, wie er tut. Ich kann darüber reden, was ich mit ihm bislang erlebt habe. Es ist in der Tat so, dass er mir am Anfang gesagt hat, dass bevor die Homepage das erste Mal gelauncht wurde, Football Leaks ungefähr ein halbes Jahr lang eine Infrastruktur aufgebaut hat, damit sie funktionieren können. So hat er es mal genannt, damit sie genug Verträge haben, damit sie genug Dokumente haben und damit sie auch genug Manpower haben, um das stemmen zu können. Ich habe ihn sehr oft danach gefragt, woher die Dokumente kommen und wer tatsächlich noch hinter ihm steckt, wer seine Mitstreiter sind, wer die anderen Aktivisten sind. Da hat er mir bis heute keine Antworten drauf gegeben. Er hat am Anfang auch mal überlegt, mir mit jemanden zusammen zu den ersten Treffen zu kommen. Das hat er bis heute nicht realisiert. Ich war ein einziges Mal in einem Büro, Wohnhaus, wie auch immer, in Osteuropa, bei dem ich vier andere Personen zumindest gesehen habe, die dort zwischen Küche und Zimmern sich bewegt haben. Ich habe John damals gefragt, ob diese Leute auch zu Football Leaks gehören. Auch das hat er mir nicht beantwortet, sondern mich einfach nur schief angelächelt. Das ist für uns nach wie vor ein Faszinosum. Wir können es nicht genau beantworten. Wir wissen aber, dass John beispielsweise Sicherheitsvorkehrungen gefällt hat, falls ihm mal was passiert oder falls er verhaftet wird oder sonst was. Der ganze Football Leaks Apparat funktioniert im Prinzip wie eine tickende Zeitbombe. An unterschiedlichen Stellen auf der Welt sind offenbar Computer scharf geschaltet. Wenn innerhalb von sieben Tagen ein bestimmter Code eingegeben wird, so erklärte er mir das mal, dann würden peu à peu seine Dokumente an die WikiLeaks-Homepage gesendet werden, also an den anonymen Großkasten und gleichzeitig auch ausgewählten weiteren Medien zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Also das hatte er von vornherein immer so gesagt, weil er gesagt hat, dass dieses Projekt unabhängig von ihm als Person leben muss, dass es auch eine Struktur aufgebaut hat, dass es leben kann, selbst wenn er nicht mehr dem ganzen vorstehen sollte oder sich dafür zeigen sollte. Ja und ansonsten zu der anderen Frage, ob er immer noch sich einer Gefahr aussetzt. Also er spürt diese Gefahr sehr stark. Wir haben Dokumente gesehen, aus denen hervorging, dass private Detektive nach ihm suchen, dass Spielerberater Agenturen beauftragt haben, seine Anonymität zu lüften und seinen Ort, den Lebenswohnraum zu ergründen, seine Familie zu finden, all sowas. Diese Gefahr spürt er massiv. Wir unterhalten uns auch da oftmals darüber. Mal gibt es Wochen, in denen es ihm damit besser geht, weil er dann eher das Gefühl hat, dass er seinen Heschern vielleicht ein bisschen entkommen ist. Dann gibt es Wochen, bei denen er das Gefühl hat, sie sind sehr nah an ihm dran. Also es ist sehr unterschiedlich und zeigt uns, dass er auch als Person im Vorfeld schon sehr vorausschauend dafür gesorgt hat, seine Lebenssituation so zu gestalten, dass er sich selbst auch in der Lage ist zu schützen. Zumindest bis zu einer gewissen Grenze.
Deutet denn das, was ihr in den Football Leaks finden könnt, kann man daraus eine dahinterstehende Agenda rekonstruieren? Erstmal ist es ja etwas altruistisches zu sagen, wir decken das jetzt einfach auf, aber vielleicht auch qua der Herkunft der Daten lag erstmal ein Fokus auf Portugal, auch auf Spanien. Hast du manchmal die Befürchtung gehabt bei der Arbeit mit Football Leaks, dass auch die Daten, die ihr zu sehen bekommt, nur extra aus einer Richtung kommen oder kannst du diese Bedenken zerstreuen?
Also ich war am Anfang, muss ich ehrlich sagen, etwas skeptisch, weil wir übermäßig viel Jorge Mendes Real Madrid Zeug hatten. Zumindest, das hat sich dann hinterher herausgestellt, dass er so ein bisschen unsere Bubble war, weil wir in dem Material sehr, sehr schnell festgestellt haben, dass es eben diese Steuer-Rutschen rund um die Mendes-Spieler gibt und insbesondere bei Cristiano Ronaldo. Und wir haben uns dann sehr exzessiv damit beschäftigt und zwar nahezu ein Jahr lang haben wir versucht, das Ganze so ein bisschen auseinander zu dröseln. Aber da gab es schon so einen Punkt bei mir, bei dem ich gedacht habe, warum ist hier jetzt gerade so viel Real Madrid und Jorge Mendes Zeug? Jetzt, wenn ich das nach zweieinhalb Jahren resümiere, muss ich zu dem Schluss kommen, es gibt keinen einzigen Verein, keinen einzigen Spieler, der aus meiner Sicht bewusst geschont wird. Wir haben Zeug über Real Madrid, über Barcelona, über Valencia, über Sevilla, über Manchester United, Manchester City, Paris Saint-Germain, Bayern, München. Auch bei den großen Beratern ist jeder große Name mit dabei, bei den großen Verbänden, die sind komplett mit dabei. Es ist wie ein riesiger Einblick in den gesamten internationalen Top-Fußball. Ich sehe nicht, von welcher Seite diese Dokumente hätten stärker beeinflusst werden können, oder welche Seite übermäßig präsent war oder nicht präsent war. Diese Sorge ist mir auch genommen worden, weil wir als Journalisten auch oftmals diskutiert haben, kann es sein, dass wir irgendwie instrumentalisiert werden? Gibt es eine dritte Kraft, die jetzt gerade versucht, irgendjemanden bewusst zu schädigen? Nach all den Enthüllungen sehen wir das nicht, sehen das an keiner Stelle. Es ist auch John selbst – und das ist uns eigentlich das Wichtigste – hat uns nicht ein einziges Mal in die Art, wie wir veröffentlichen oder was wir veröffentlichen, reingefuchtelt. Der übergibt uns diese riesigen Materialberge und der hat niemals gesagt, aber diese Geschichte dürft ihr machen oder diese Geschichte dürft ihr nicht machen. Sondern wir arbeiten an den Football Leaks komplett unabhängig und selbstständig, so wie wir das beim Spiegel auch tagtäglich gewohnt sind. Wir hätten da auch keinen anderen Deal mitgemacht. Der einzige Deal, den wir mit Football Leaks haben, ist eben, seine Anonymität so zu schützen, wie wir das schützen können. Aber das ist eigentlich selbstverständlich im investigativen Journalismus, dass man bei der Quellenlage auch genau das tut und ich nicht verrate, wie er aussieht oder wo er lebt oder wo er sich aktuell aufhält. Sondern, dass wir das alles für uns behalten. Das ist die einzige Absprache, an die ich mich halte. Ansonsten arbeiten wir mit dem Material vollkommen frei und unabhängig. Und wenn man dann auch noch die Info dazu bekommt, dass der absolute Lieblingsspieler von John Cristiano Ronaldo ist.
Das ist eben das Paradoxe, weil wir haben dazu auch einige Fragen bekommen, die gesagt haben, die das auch so ein bisschen kritisiert haben, dass sie euch zu Beginn der Veröffentlichung auf Cristiano Ronaldo fokussiert haben und die gesagt haben, genau das hat ihnen das Thema so schnell ein bisschen überdrüssig werden lassen, dieser Fokus auf diesen einen Spieler. Wie begegnest du dem?
Also wir haben genau eine Geschichte zu Cristiano Ronaldo am Anfang gemacht, in dieser Dezemberwelle. Das war die Publikationswelle. Das war der erste Titel, den wir auch noch als Split-Titel hatten. Also auf der einen Seite war das ein Titel zu Cristiano Ronaldo, auf der anderen Seite war das ein Titel zu Mesut Özil. Und auch in der Geschichte um Cristiano Ronaldo ist es nicht nur um Cristiano Ronaldo gegangen, sondern wir haben das System, wie wir es genannt haben, das System Mendes beschrieben. Also auch mit all den anderen Spielern, die diese Form von Steuerrutschen in Offshore-Länder benutzt haben. Das war keineswegs ein Portrait über Cristiano Ronaldo.
Aber es kam vielleicht ein bisschen so an, dadurch dass es auch der plakativste Fall ist. Vielleicht auch deshalb, weil es eben der größte Spieler gerade ist, neben Lionel Messi und man auch die größten Stars. Da ist der mögliche Absturz oder die möglichen Abgründe sind besonders interessant und deswegen hat sich vielleicht auch die Aufmerksamkeit der Öffentlichkeit automatisch auch ein bisschen auf ihn fokussiert.
Naja und was dann für uns ja auch dazu kam, war, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft relativ zügig nach unseren Veröffentlichungen festgestellt hat, Hoppla, der Typ hat tatsächlich knapp 15 Millionen Steuern hinterzogen und wir wollen hier ein Prozess, wir wollen, dass dieses Verfahren gegen den eröffnet wird und in dem Moment, in dem die Justiz im Prinzip das so aufnimmt, ist es ja auch für uns ein sehr wichtiges Element, das weiter fortzuführen und fortzuschreiben und auch unseren Lesern, die sich dann dafür interessieren, die Einblicke zu geben, wie es weitergeht. Dazu muss man sagen, dass relativ zügig nach der Steuergeschichte ja auch noch diese mutmaßliche Vergewaltigungsgeschichte rund um Cristiano Ronaldo von uns aufgebohrt wurde oder wir eben zeigen konnten, dass in den Dokumenten sich auch dazu etwas findet. Möglicherweise sind das die Gründe, warum man irgendwann festgestellt hat, es sind sieben oder acht Geschichten über Cristiano Ronaldo gewesen. Wir haben insgesamt bei den Football Leaks Berichterstattungen zwischen Dezember und Ende Januar über 400 Texte europaweit zu allen unterschiedlichen Schwerpunkten. Da ging es um Agenten, um Jugendspieler, um financial fair play, um Korruption und Bestechung. Es war sehr breit gefächert, aber wenn man dann, keine Ahnung, aus diesen beiden Segmenten – Steuerhinterziehung und mutmaßliche Vergewaltigung, wenn daraus sieben oder acht Geschichten entstehen, mag es vielleicht am Ende auch so sein, dass Cristiano Ronaldo dann sehr stark in den Fokus geraten ist. Aber auch da bin ich Realist. Ein Journalist schreibt nur das, was er gerade zur Verfügung hat. Wenn ich die Möglichkeit gehabt hätte, an der Stelle auch noch über Uli Hoeneß zu schreiben oder über Hans-Johann Watzke oder Bernd Hoffmann oder Weiß der Geier, dann hätte ich das sicherlich auch in der größten Ordnung gemacht. Aber wenn die Dokumente eben in erster Linie Cristiano Ronaldo, Jorge Mendes, und Real Madrid so stark in den Fokus heben, weil die Justiz eben danach auch dazu oder dass das Ganze quasi mit mitbearbeitet und es zu einem möglichen Verfahren kommt, es ein internationales Thema wird, dann bleibt uns eben auch nichts anderes übrig, als diese Sachen so fortzuschreiben. Auch auf die Gefahr hin, dass der ein oder andere des Themas überdrüssig wird.
Das lenkt jetzt aber auch schon so ein bisschen den Blick auf dich. Wir haben jetzt darüber gesprochen, wie es John geht, ob er sich beobachtet fühlt, ob er um sein Leben fürchten muss. Wir haben auch von mehreren Hörern und Hörern die Fragen nach dir bekommen. Fühlst du dich beobachtet? Ich habe mir diese Frage auch gestellt, als wir per Mail Kontakt hatten, dachte ich mir auch, liest da jetzt mit, sollte ich nicht doch langsam meine PGP-Verschlüsselung für meine Mails anwerfen, obwohl wir da ja erst mal nur über den Termin hier gesprochen haben. Aber wie geht es dir selbst jetzt nach diesen Enthüllungen?
Ich finde, dass ein Journalist sich nicht selbst zu wichtig nehmen sollte, noch seine eigene Rolle nicht zu sehr überhöhen sollte.
Ja, aber du hast die Frage danach bekommen, deswegen darfst du jetzt schon…
Ich würde sie aber mit der gebotenen Demut zu beantworten, weil für mich im Fokus der Whistleblower steht und seine Rolle steht. Meine Rolle orientiert sich an der Rolle des Whistleblowers. Das bedeutet für mich, dass ich beispielsweise meine Anreisewege verändern muss. Wir haben festgestellt, dass es Menschen gibt, die offenbar auch ein hohes Interesse daran haben, zu sehen, wie ich mich bewege. Dementsprechend muss ich mir überlegen, wie kann ich das machen.
Wie stellt man sowas fest? Dass da jemand mit einer Zeitung in der zwei Augenschlitze reingeschnitten war?
Das stellt man zum Beispiel fest, indem man in Hamburg auf einer U-Bahn wartet und die ganze Zeit sieht, dass ein Mensch daneben steht, der dort auch komischerweise ab und zu mal rüber guckt und wartet. Da ich ein ziemlich verpeilter Mensch bin, was Reisestrukturen angeht, fällt mir dann kurz vorher auf, dass ich am falschen Bahngleis stehe, das Bahngleis wechsle und lustigerweise dieser Mensch mir folgt. Ich dann einige Tage später an meinem Heimatbahnhof aussteige, die Treppe runter gehe, mich nochmal umdrehe, um auf die Uhr zu gucken und feststelle, dass dieser Mensch in dem Moment abbiegt und in eine Buchhandlung geht. Und dann stehe ich ein paar Wochen später in Las Vegas am Strip, weil wir dort eben diese Vergewaltigungsgeschichte rund um Christiane Ronaldo recherchiert haben und sehe den Menschen wieder. Und stelle dann eben fest, entweder sind wir Seelenverwandte oder er hat zwingend die gleichen Interessen wie ich oder er ist halt beauftragt. Dann fängt man eben an, sich zu überlegen, wie man seine Reiserouten verändert, wie man möglicherweise Reiserouten so aufbaut, dass ein Mensch einem nicht auf direkten Wege folgen kann. Damit meine ich jetzt nicht die normalen Reiserouten zur Arbeit oder wenn ich keine Ahnung nach Berlin reise oder sonst was, sondern die Reiserouten zu John. Die sind mittlerweile schon ziemlich kompliziert. Ich kann nicht einfach ins Flugzeug steigen und lande an Ort XY, bin dann bei ihm, sondern muss mir dazwischen überlegen, wie ich Unterbrechungen einlege, welche Teile ich vielleicht mit dem Auto fahre, mit dem Zug fahre, wann ich möglicherweise doch noch mal das Hotelzimmer wechsle. All diese Faktoren spielen damit rein. Das schließt immer noch nicht aus, dass man irgendeinen Schnüffler losliert, aber es gibt zumindest gute Möglichkeiten, es hinzubekommen. Natürlich, aber das sind so Basics, dass ich meine SIM-Karten wechsle, dass ich kein GPS anhabe, dass ich mein im Ausland oder in der Kommunikation mit John nur verschlüsselt agiere, auch nur mit einem 2 oder 3. Handy, dass ich SIM-Karten früh entsorge. All diese Sachen, die kommen mit dazu, die kommen aber auch, die sind jetzt nicht nur John spezifisch, sondern sie sind, das passiert oftmals, wenn man mit sehr, sehr weichen Quellen zu tun hat und weiche Quellen heißt eine Person, die ein Geheimnis trägt und wenn sie uns das Geheimnis sagt, sich selbst massiv in Gefahr begibt. Dann muss ich als Journalist dafür, das sind Basics, die wir beim Spiegel sehr früh lernen oder die uns sehr, sehr früh an die Hand gegeben werden, dass wir dann auf bestimmte Verhaltensmuster Rücksicht nehmen, dass wir Hardware nutzen, Software nutzen, dass wir uns sehr klare Gedanken machen, wie wir diese Person mit all unseren Mitteln schützen können.
Ja, da kommt mir aber gleich wieder in den Sinn, dass du vorhin noch gesagt hast, dass du gerade mein Computer an- und ausschalten kannst. Das ist ja ein hochtechnologisches Thema und wenn ich dann zum Beispiel das jetzt ein bisschen Nerd-Talk entschuldigt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber vor ein paar Tagen, nicht allzu lange her, wurde bekannt, dass manche PGP-Verschlüsselungen inzwischen auch nicht mehr sicher verschlüsselt sind. Nicht alle generell, aber das heißt, man muss ja auch immer auf dem Laufenden bleiben, was quasi den aktuellen State-of-the-Art-Verschlüsselungsmechanismen im Digitalen betrifft und kann sich dann dennoch sehr sicher sein, dass diejenigen, die versuchen, sowas zu knacken, immer einen Vorsprung haben. Denn wir erfahren ja auch nur einen ganz kleinen Teil davon. Und ich kenne zum Beispiel auch einen Journalisten, der sehr viel im Bereich der Geheimdienste recherchiert, was der mir für Geschichten erzählt, was der tun muss, um seine digitalen Spuren zu verwischen. Das ist dann für mich schon sehr komplex und ich würde mich als jemanden bezeichnen, der eher technologieaffin ist. Wie kannst du das denn leisten?
Ja, also das ist in Wahrheit auch eine gewisse Steuerung, die dann der Whistleblower vornimmt, indem mir der Whistleblower oder John sagt, über welche Kanäle er mit mir sprechen möchte und diese Kanäle mir dann an die Hand gibt. Mir dann sagt, wo ich mich einloggen kann, wie ich mich einloggen kann, was ich mir runterladen muss. Dem folge ich dann und versuche, diese von ihm gewählten Kanäle dann auch zu nutzen. Es ist in der Regel so, dass er selten einen verschlüsselten Chat über einen längeren Zeitraum benutzt. Er benutzt auch keine PGPs. Als ich ihm das erste Mal gesagt habe, dass ich ihn gerne PGP schreiben möchte, hat er mich lauthaft ausgelacht, weil er einfach gesagt hat, das ist okay, wenn wir das machen, können wir uns auch direkt Postkarten zuschicken. Das hat er mir vor zweieinhalb Jahren schon gesagt. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Es gibt Kanäle, die für mich, wenn ich ehrlich bin, eine völlig neue Welt waren und auch ein bisschen mich erschrocken haben, weil ich mit so etwas vorher noch nie gearbeitet habe. Ich möchte jetzt die Namen der einzelnen Chat-Räume natürlich nicht benennen, aber es gibt Chat-Räume, in denen ich beispielsweise eine Nachricht schicke und innerhalb von 15 Sekunden, nachdem der Satz aufgetaucht ist in diesem Chat-Bereich, wird der Satz auch wieder gelöscht, also von alleine. Das heißt, in dem Moment kann man das Handy nicht weglegen, sondern er schreibt mir dann über Chat A, dass wir uns jetzt in Chat D treffen. Dann gehe ich in diesen Chat D und dort schreiben wir dann quasi im Live-Modus. Ich schreibe ihm meine Nachricht, liest er und sie wird in diesen 15 Sekunden gelöscht. Er schreibt mir zurück, seine Nachricht wird gelöscht, ich schreibe meine Nachricht, die wird gelöscht. So dass es im Prinzip auch keine oder es schwer ist für jemanden A in der Geschwindigkeit dort reinzukommen und B dann auch mitlesen zu können. Das ist fast alles, was wir nutzen, ist auch mit einem dreifachen oder. Vierfachen Passwortschlüssel im Vorfeld gesichert. Das ist eine Art Zufallsgenerator, der in Verbindung mit einem Passwort oder mit einem weiteren digitalen Fingerabdruck die Möglichkeit gibt, bestimmte Räume betreten zu können. Und so sichern wir unsere Kommunikation ab. Das ist in Wahrheit – ich hab das ja auch im Buch mal ausformuliert – ich wünsche jedem Geheimdienst viel Spaß dabei, der das lesen möchte, weil es teilweise ja auch nicht nur um die dreckigen Geschäfte im Fußball geht, sondern wir dann auch gemeinsam ein Spiel sezieren und wir uns über die Taktik dieses Spiels unterhalten und er mir seinen Eindruck gibt, warum Real Madrid gerade Bayern München besiegt und womit das zusammenhinkt. Und ich ihm dann erkläre, wo ich die Schwächen von Bayern München gesehen habe oder die Stärken von Real Madrid. Wenn das ein Geheimdienst mitliest, dann wird er nach kürzester Zeit, glaube ich, auch die Krise kriegen, weil dann auch schon viel blödsinnige Quatsche auch mit dabei natürlich ist, wie ganz normale Fußballzuschauer sich eben dann auch das ein oder andere Mal über ein Spiel unterhalten.
Ich glaube, dass man da zwar sehr viel lernen könnte, aber ja, ich verstehe da.
Genau, also er ist auch soweit, das muss ich echt sagen, er ist soweit Fußball fit, dass er auch taktische Elemente sehen kann, dass er über Fußball als solche sehr, sehr detailliert und tief reden kann. Ich habe das jetzt so ein bisschen spöttisch und abwertend gesagt, aber das, was er unterschreibt, ist teilweise auch schon sehr spannend. Das macht Spaß, aber es gibt kein Erkenntnisgewinn für einen Geheimdienst, wenn er da mitlesen möchte. Deshalb haben wir auch unterschiedliche Sicherheitsstufen, bei den Chats, die wir nutzen. Diese Sicherheitsstufen sind in erster Linie damit oder hängen damit zusammen, welche Passwortelemente man im Vorfeld eingibt. Für den einen oder anderen Chatraum brauche ich auch 20 Minuten, bevor ich da überhaupt drin bin.
Das ist fast, als würden wir über Skype zu Football Leaks telefonieren.
Das sind in Wahrheit Chaträume, die auch unsere IT oftmals gar nicht kennen, die ich im Vorfeld nicht gekannt habe, die aber John kennt. Ich bewege mich damit auch in einem Raum rein, in dem ich anfange, mich mit solchen Dingen zu beschäftigen und feststelle, wie bestimmte Whistleblower sich zu schützen in der Lage sind oder über was sie sprechen wollen. Das ist ein spannendes Feld, auch wenn ich wie gesagt technisch davon einfach keine Ahnung habe, aber zumindest in der Endbenutzung gelingt es mir ab und an.
Ja, aber auch jetzt wird es dann ein journalistisches Thema, deswegen stelle ich nur kurze These in den Raum. Aber Whistleblower müssen inzwischen auch ein Grundwissen an digitalen Verschleierungstaktiken mitbringen. Es reicht eben heutzutage nicht mehr, eine Steuersünde-CD irgendwo hinzuschicken oder einer Zeitung in einem Tiefgarage irgendetwas zuzuflüstern, sondern heutzutage bedeutet Whistleblower sein auch, dass man digital sehr, sehr weit vorne mit dabei sein muss, in einem Bereich, den man wahrscheinlich schlecht ergoogeln kann, denn sonst würden sie ja alle tun, vermute ich einfach mal. Absolut.
Um das nur mal kurz einzureißen, die Digitalisierung ist oftmals ein Segen für den normalen Alltagsgebrauch. Für die investigative Arbeit ist sie aber die Hölle eigentlich. Weil sehr, sehr viele Quellen entweder mittlerweile komplett darauf verzichten, sich digital auszutauschen. Dann wird eben ganz simpel von einer toten SIM-Karte einmal auf ein Festnetz angerufen. Und zwar auf ein Festnetz, das im Vorfeld als genau das bezeichnet wurde, eben als Sorgenstation, auf die man dann an einem Tag in der Woche anruft und dann beide sich im Vorfeld bei ihrem persönlichen Termin darauf verständigt haben. Und dann werden Termine ausgemacht, persönliche Termine. Ich habe Ermittler und Fahnder, die, wenn ich mich mit denen treffe, das ist mittlerweile schon echt hochgradige Paranoia. Da darf kein Handy mit, da darf kein Computer mit. Ich kann noch nicht einmal mit meinem eigenen Auto im Vorfeld anfahren, die tun es auch nicht. Und dann trifft man sich an Orten, die tatsächlich sehr, sehr blickgeschützt sind und ich mir dann manchmal auch frage, wo ich eigentlich, in welcher Welt ich eigentlich lebe, weil mir das dann auch schon so ein bisschen zu sehr nach Kino und zu sehr nach James-Borne-Filmen vorkommt.
Im Umgang mit heiklen Quellen ist es sehr gut, wenn man manchmal auch Namen vergisst.
Vor allem, wenn man dann hinterher befragt wird.
Ja, genau, wenn dich dann irgendwelche Leute in langen Podcasts grillen. Aber du schaffst es ja sehr gut, alles zu um Schiffen. Wir haben noch ein paar Fragen und zwar zum Teil auch, sehr konkrete Fragen. Da geht es noch einmal bei der einen um die Hintergründe der – ja, das Wisseblower John und vielleicht einer Agenda. Und zwar hat Zerstreuung Fußball zwei Zitate mitgebracht aus dem Buch und dazu konkrete Fragen gestellt. Das eine ist ein Zitat, es sind jetzt beides Mails, die von John stammen sollen oder zumindest von ihm gesagt wurden. Das eine Zitat ist, unser Antrieb ist es, all denen das Handwerk zu legen, die sich zu Unrecht an dem Volkssport Fußball bereichern. Und das zweite Zitat zahlt darauf ein, das lautet, diese Leute kontrollieren den europäischen Fußball und machen dabei unentwegt miteinander Geschäfte unter dem Tisch. Spieler und Vereine werden durch sie zu Marionetten. Wir haben Dokumente, die das belegen. Wenn du sie liest, wirst du dir die Frage stellen, wie man überhaupt noch an diesen Sport glauben kann. Und er äußert sich jetzt dahingehend dazu, dass er sagt, dass diese Sätze recht unkommentiert stehen gelassen wurden, deswegen will er dich dazu eben noch mal befragen. Und er findet vor allem das zweite Zitat, wo es eben dann um diese Leute, die den europäischen Fußball kontrollieren, geht, ein bisschen problematisch. Denn er fragt ja, welche Dokumente sind damit gemeint und gibt es tatsächlich eine kleine Gruppe von Menschen, die den komplettischen europäischen Fußball kontrolliert? Oder wie war das vermutlich gemeint von John?
Schwierige Frage, weil ich sie so auch nicht beantworten kann. Das hängt so ein bisschen auch mit dem whistleblower zusammen. Manche dieser Formulierung lässt er auch so stehen. Ich habe sehr bewusst versucht, im Buch mich nah an der Person zu halten und auch wenn man wenig über ihn sagen kann, zumindest die Charakteristiken dieses Menschen wiederzugeben. Auch auf Nachfrage, wer denn genau damit gemeint ist, wird er selten konkreter. Er sagt dann, guck dir die Berater an, ich zeige dir hier die Dokumente. Und dann gibt es eben Dokumente, die Jorge Mendes zum Beispiel betreffen, bei denen ich bis dahin ja immer gedacht habe, er ist ein normaler Spielerberater und wir dann mit den Dokumenten feststellen, ist er nicht. Er hat Fonds, über die mit anderen gemeinsam in Vereine investiert wird. Er verkauft Anteile seiner Firma an chinesische Investoren, um dann gemeinsam in Fußballvereine wieder zu investieren oder zu reinvestieren. Er unterhält sehr, sehr enge Geschäftsbeziehungen zu Präsidenten von Vereinen, wie zum Beispiel Lim von Valencia, der lustigerweise dann auch noch die Bildrechte von Cristiano Ronaldo ankauft. Das muss man sich vorstellen, der Präsident des FC Valencia kauft die Bildrechte eines Fußballers, eines direkten Konkurrenten von Real Madrid. Das ganze läuft natürlich auch mit Gestaltung von Jorge Mendes. Dann zeigt mir John Documento von Mino Raiola, der an einem Transfer von Paul Pogba 49 Millionen verdient, weil er eben sowohl Bioventus Turin als auch Manchester United als auch mit Paul Pogba zusammenarbeitet. Daran sieht man, dass John uns versucht, natürlich in die groben Machenschaften von der ein oder anderen Person Einblicke zu verschaffen, aber das ich bislang noch nicht gesehen habe, was er mit einer Agenda meint. Ich habe immer von ihm verstanden, dass er, egal in welches Segment des Fußballs er reingeschaut hat, festgestellt hat, dass dort irgendetwas nicht mit rechten Dingen zuging und dass er immer wieder auch formuliert und sagt, der Fußball ist eine so enorme Blase. Im Fußball selbst kommen immer wieder die gleichen Player zugeltend, immer wieder die gleichen Personen haben miteinander zu tun und dieses Business lebt von den Personen, die seit Jahrzehnten eigentlich in einem Vertrauensverhältnis zueinander stehen. Und wenn diese Personen dauerhaft voneinander profitieren, sind sie ja auch nicht in der Lage, nach außen irgendjemanden zu belasten, weil du belastest niemanden, von dem du so massiv profitierst und vielleicht beim nächsten Transfer wieder profitierst oder bei der nächsten Beteiligung an irgendeinem Verein profitierst. John hat immer wieder gesagt, durch diese Intransparenz und durch den Einfluss von Superagenten – und damit meinte er immer Leute wie Mendez, wie Rayola, wie Simonian, auch Sahavi, all diese echten Großmeister – durch diesen Einfluss passiert es auch, dass teilweise die Spieler zwischen den Vereinen wie Marionetten hin und her geschoben werden. Wenn Mino Rayola in einem Transferfenster Mikitarian, Pokba und Ibrahimovic bei Manchester United unterbringen kann, dann ist dieser Berater ein enormer Einfluss auf einen der absoluten Spitzenvereine in Europa. Das gleiche gilt für Mendez, der das sehr gezielt mit bestimmten Vereinen macht. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt meine Interpretation dessen, worum es John in diesen Zitaten geht, weil er, seitdem ich mit ihm zu tun habe, immer wieder genau diese Sachen erzählt und wiedergibt. Aber ansonsten ist es nicht so, dass er ein so stringenter Mensch ist, der seine Zitate, die ihm zwischendurch auch mal einfallen, großartig erklärt. Sondern er sagt sie und dann lässt er sie auch mal im Raum stehen, auch wenn eine Nachfrage kommt, lässt er sie im Raum stehen und denkt dann weiter darüber nach, was er als nächstes sagt oder wo wir als nächstes hingehen oder was wir als nächstes essen. Da sind Menschen eben auch unterschiedlich und ich versuche, seine Eigenheiten zu akzeptieren, weil ich eben dann auch nur alle paar Wochen mit ihm zu tun habe. Wenn er jetzt ein direkter Arbeitskollege wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich dann auch schon irgendwann mal sagen, nimm mal zu, das musst du mir näher erklären oder darüber müssen wir detaillierter sprechen. Das kann man mit einem Whistleblower in der Form nicht machen, wenn er selbst – das ist ein sehr verschwiegender Mensch, das muss man dazusagen – dass er, der schafft es auch oft, egal in welchem Aggregatzustand er sich gerade befindet, eben dann auch auf Sachen nicht zu antworten, wenn man sich das wünscht. Wenn man diese Antwort gerade haben möchte und John sie aber nicht haben oder sie nicht geben möchte, dann tut er das auch nicht.
Ja, irgendwie ja auch alles ganz gut erklärbar. Und wenn wir schon bei dieser Frage nach wenigen großen Superagenten und Marionetten und so weiter im Geschäft sind, dann kann ich da auch noch eine Frage anschließen, die Marc Wiese gestellt hat, der dich auch mal für den Sportjournalist interviewt hat. Er lässt dich herzlich grüßen an dieser Stelle.
Vielen Dank, schöne Grüße zurück.
Ihn würde interessieren, ob und wenn ja mit welchen Vereinen Dorian Sports derzeit in Anführungszeichen kooperiert. Gibt es noch Geschäftsmodelle, die ähnlich sind zu dem damaligen mit Wente Enskede? Also bereichert sich Dorian weiter an klammen Clubs?
Dazu muss ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil Dorian nach wie vor eine Geschichte für uns ist und ich so sehr ich euren Podcasts schätze, Spiegelgeschichten auch im Podcast nicht vorgreifen kann, aber darauf hinweisen kann, dass wir Dorian Sports nach wie vor im Auge haben und nach wie vor über sie schreiben wollen und weiterschreiben wollen. Es ist so, dass die Firma sich aktuell völlig neu strukturiert, dass sie ihren Geschäftsitz gerade verlagert hat, erneut in eine Steueroase nach Dubai, dass sie immer noch in dem Geschäft tätig ist, aber dass sie ihr Geschäftsfeld ein bisschen verändert hat. So viel kann ich, glaube ich, jetzt hier schon verraten und alles andere werde ich zu gegebener Zeit dann auch mal posten.
Sehr gut, Herr Cliffhanger. Ich glaube, es hat das Näschen von Mark Wiese bewiesen. Er hat da auf die richtige Stelle gezeigt und du hättest ja auch einfach nur antworten können mit Ja, aber du hast jetzt ein etwas längeres und umständlicheres Ja gemacht und den Rest müssen wir dann einfach abwarten.
Ja, das Problem natürlich auch an der Form des Podcasts – und ich hoffe, dass das die Leser verstehen – ist, dass ich versuche, so viel Transparenz wie möglich in meine Arbeit reinzubekommen, aber natürliche Grenzen in dieser Transparenz habe. Ich kann nicht über alles sprechen, weil ich eben sowohl die Quelle schützen muss, als auch die Interessen meines Hauses schützen muss und zwar über Geschichten, die nicht geschrieben und nicht konfrontiert sind, natürlich im Vorfeld auch nicht sprechen darf oder sprechen kann. Bevor ich etwas über eine Firma, über die Zukunft einer Firma sage, muss ich natürlich auch als seriöser Journalist dieser Firma die Möglichkeit geben, ein Statement dazu abzugeben. Und wenn ich das dann habe, bin ich gerne in der Situation, darüber bei euch auch im Podcast zu sprechen.
Das werden wir sicherlich auch noch häufiger tun. Zuletzt würde ich gerne noch einen anderen Aspekt beleuchten, den eben die Hörerinnen und Hörer aufgeworfen haben. Es ist ja so ein bisschen eure Sendung. Wir haben jetzt schon darüber gesprochen, was die Justiz gemacht hat nach den Veröffentlichungen der Football Leaks. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, welche Dinge sich verändert haben für den Whistleblower und auch für dich. Und jetzt gab es auch noch einige Fragen logischerweise zur möglichen Reaktion der Verbände und des Fußballs an sich. Und da hat unter anderem Piszczdy geschrieben, warum ist es eigentlich nicht so, dass zum Beispiel DFL die DFL in ihren Lizenzierungsunterlagen nicht nur so Dinge festsetzt, wie ein Stadion muss überdacht sein und über 10.000 Sitze haben und Parkplatzgrößen, sondern auch Corporate Governance Forderungen und Transparenzansprüche da reinschreibt. Er nennt da einige Beispiele, die sehr, die eben, wenn man sich mit diesem Bereich auseinandersetzt, man aus anderen Branchen eben kennt, dass alle Personen in Organfunktionen, juristische Personen unter Vorstrafen sind, dass es Kontrollmechanismen gibt, dass die Lizenz verweigert werden kann, wenn bestimmte Transparenzansprüchen nicht Rechnung getragen wird. Er geht da sehr ins Detail. Aber was hältst du denn davon? Was könnte er denn oder was müsste denn der Fußball tun, um jetzt darauf zu reagieren, was ihr da alles jetzt aufdecken konntet und könnt?
Das ist das Naheliegende aus all den dunklen Geschäften, die wir jetzt auch beschreiben, dass man genau diese Sachen implementiert, dass man eben nicht irgendeine Ethikkommission gründet, die mit ehemaligen Politikern besetzt wird, die mittlerweile aus dem Geschäft raus sind, um ein Feigenblatt zu haben oder Aufsichtsräte zu gründen, wo ausschließlich Freunde und Förderer des Vereins drin sitzen, sondern dass es sehr, sehr verbindliche Compliance und New-Diligence-Formulierungen, Regularien im Fußball gibt, dass selbstverständlich eine Transparenz bei Verbänden in viel, viel höherer Form von den jeweiligen Vereinen eingefordert werden muss. Dass es beispielsweise so etwas geben muss wie Clearing Houses eigentlich. Das ist eine Forderung, die eigentlich von John kommt, der ich mich aber inhaltlich schon auch anschließen kann, weil ich glaube, dass sie dem Fußball extrem weiterhelfen würde, wenn man nicht eben nur wie die DFL jedes Jahr vermeldet, dass die Ausgaben für Spielerberater sich wieder um 50 Prozent oder 100 Prozent gesteigert haben, sondern dass man eben auch Handwerkszeug oder Werkzeug entwickelt, um herauszufinden, wo diese Gelder hingehen, wer sie eigentlich erhalten hat, wie die Geldflüsse der jeweiligen Vereine diesbezüglich ausgesehen haben. Und zwar nicht nur bis zum ersten Stroman, sondern bis zu allen Firmen, die an einem solchen Deal beteiligt sind. Ja, selbstverständlich wären das genau die Konsequenzen, die eigentlich ein Verband oder die Verbände daraus ziehen müssten. Wir sehen aber oder stellen fest, dass es viel einfacher ist im Fußball, solange auch kein Druck von Justiz und Politik da ist, eben genau das andere zu sagen. Und zu sagen, wir machen jetzt hier zwei, drei kleinere Feigenblätter und werden ansonsten schon irgendwie da durchkommen, weil morgen das nächste Spiel ist und das nächste schöne Tor ist. Und am Ende, dass natürlich dann auch jegliche Form von Kritik so ein bisschen erdrückt. Daran hängen sich ja Verbände auch intensiv auf. Wir haben nach den Football Leaks mal mit Gianni Infantino ein langes Interview geführt, bei dem er lang und breit uns erklärt hat, dass er sich das alles angucken wird.
Das war legendär, legendär. Was er alles nicht wusste, das hatte fast schon Niersbach Dimensionen.
Ja, total, total. Das war wie ein Reh auf einer Eisplatte, von links nach rechts gerutscht, keine klare Aussage. Seitdem ist bei der FIFA ja diesbezüglich nichts passiert. Es ist immer noch ein totales Eldorado für Spielerberater, sich in diesem Business zu bewegen, weil es immer noch keine echten Regularien gibt. Die FIFA hat einfach da die weiße Fahne gehisst vor einigen Jahren und hat gesagt, die Spielerberater werden jetzt von den Nationalverbänden reglementiert oder reguliert. Die Nationalverbände sagen, wie zur Hölle sollen wir das tun, wenn das natürlich ein globales Business ist. Wir können dann nur das abbilden, was hier in Deutschland passiert. Wenn es da nicht ernsthafte Bemühungen gibt und zwar sowohl vom Weltverband als auch vom Europäischen Verband, dem ein bisschen mehr entgegenzusetzen als nur zu sagen, wir werden uns das angucken, dann wird sich da auch selbstverständlich nichts ändern, bis irgendwann mal die Justiz eingreift und ebenso ähnlich wie es damals bei der FIFA war, es zu großen Razzien, zu großen Hausdurchsuchungen kommt und das Ganze auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Wir sehen jetzt schon, welche groben Sorgen und auch Vorsichtsmaßnahmen, beispielsweise in Spanien oder Portugal, auch in Teilen in Frankreich in Bezug auf die Versteuerung von Bildrechten vorgenommen werden und wie sensibilisiert mittlerweile Verbände und Vereine diesbezüglich sind, weil sie durch unsere Berichterstattung enorm aufgeschreckt wurden. Ich lege da auch beide Hände für ins Feuer, dass in den nächsten Monaten noch deutlich mehr an Ermittlungsverfahren da auch auf die jeweiligen Vereine und Spieler zukommen wird. Von solchen Dingen würde man eigentlich von einer solchen Multimilliardenbranche erwarten, dass sie sie auch schon versucht zu lösen, bevor das Problem tatsächlich öffentlich wird, also dass sie versucht damit umzugehen, bevor der große Knall da ist. Aber der Fußball – und das sehen wir auch an ganz vielen der Veröffentlichungen der letzten Jahre – reagiert erst, wenn ihm irgendwas auf die Füße gefallen ist. Und oftmals reagiert er dann auch nur so, dass dann die handelnden Köpfe quasi weggeschnitten werden und einfach aus dem jeweiligen Fleisch neues Fleisch nachwächst. Ja genau, das ist das ist etwas, was in der Regel dazu führt, dass solche Branchen irgendwann mal dann auch kollabieren, weil es unmöglich ist, auf Dauer ein solches Business so aufrecht zu erhalten. Wir sehen es ja jetzt schon, dass es einen Zuschauerschwund gibt, dass die Stadien nicht mehr ausverkauft sind, dass an der einen oder anderen Stelle eben das Interesse auch zurückgeht. Und das hängt mit ganz vielen dieser Entwicklungen zusammen, die nicht nur Football Leaks sind, sondern die generell den Einfluss des Geldes und auch der Profitgier im Fußball widerspiegeln. Ich bin aber, ich selbst sehe aber für uns keine großen weiteren Möglichkeiten, den Verbänden zu erklären, wie sie das lösen könnten, außer so, wie wir es machen. Und zwar indem wir Woche für Woche, Monat für Monat Enthüllungen dazu machen und ihnen zeigen, was alles nicht gut läuft.
Aber hältst du es denn realistisch, dass aus den Verbänden heraus sich da etwas tun wird? Denn die FIFA ist ja ein perfektes Beispiel. Dann kommen Korruptionsvorwürfe raus. Im Grunde kannst du so, wie man früher die ersten zehn der Tour de France dann im Jahr danach alle durchstreichen konnte, weil Doping rauskam, so kannst du bei der FIFA irgendwann im Exekutivkomitee, kannst du jetzt auch den Rutsch ansetzen und sagen, okay, ist inzwischen Korruption nachgewiesen, ist angeklagt, ist nachgewiesen, ist angeklagt. Und was passiert? Die Köpfe werden ausgetauscht, es gibt einen neuen Kopf, der Hydra und das Spiel geht weiter. Ich vermute mal, du hast einen engeren und tieferen Einblick in die FIFA und auch in die UEFA als ich. Gibt es denn da überhaupt Kräfte, in die man als Fußballfan Hoffnung setzen kann, dass sich da der Verband irgendwann selbst reguliert oder ist das komplett hoffnungslos und es müsste wenn dann über politischen oder finanziellen Druck geschehen von außen?
Ich persönlich glaube nicht, dass der Fußball in der Lage ist, sich selbst noch zu retten. Ich glaube, dass das nur funktionieren kann, wenn Politik und Justiz sich dessen viel stärker vornehmen. Und selbst dann wird es sehr, sehr lange dauern, um eine Form von Säuberung in diesem Business, in dieser Branche herzustellen. Ich glaube in der Tat, dass der Fußball das auch gar nicht möchte. Warum auch? Das ist ein Produkt, das extrem viel Geld abwirft, das extrem gut für die Leute in der Branche funktioniert. Warum sollten sie sich jetzt an der Stelle damit beschäftigen, was in zehn Jahren der Fall ist, oder was in fünf Jahren der Fall ist? Wenn ihnen ein paar Zuschauer weggehen, dann gibt es auf der Welt noch weitere Märkte, wo man Zuschauer akquirieren kann oder wo man Zuschauer finden kann. Dann geht man halt nach Asien oder nach Amerika. Die Welt ist groß und die Globalisierung funktioniert an vielen Stellen. Also ich glaube, dass es dort dieses Bedürfnis nicht gibt. Es muss von Seiten der Politik ein Aufwachen stattfinden, dass man mit dem Fußball nicht nur als Politiker glänzen kann, sondern dass es durchaus notwendig ist, dem Fußball auch genau auf die Finger zu schauen und zu sagen, brauchen wir nicht bestimmte Regularien, um die Geldflüsse, diese immensen Geldflüsse besser zu steuern. Das ist ein Vergleich möglicherweise zu der Weltwirtschaftskrise 2009. Nach der Weltwirtschaftskrise sind rund um die Banken ein deutlich schärferes Geldwäschegesetz verhängt worden. Es sind Due-Diligence- und Compliance-Regeln aufgenommen worden. Sie funktionieren auch nicht hundertprozentig, aber sie haben vieles verändert und besser gemacht. Auch das Bankengeheimnis ist an vielen Stellen zerbröselt, was ein sehr wichtiger Faktor war, um die Transparenz in absurde Geldflüsse hinein zu bekommen. Ich glaube, dass der Fußball über kurz oder lang vor einer ähnlichen Umwälzung stehen wird, weil ich persönlich auch immer wieder die Frage aufwerfe, warum all die arabischen, russischen, chinesischen Investoren seit dieser Weltwirtschaftskrise und seit den extremen Beschränkungen in Bezug auf Geldwäsche auf einmal den Fußball für sich erkannt haben und auf einmal festgestellt haben, dass es dort extreme Anreize gibt, um Gelder einsetzen zu können. Das sind Menschen, bei denen man nicht immer sagen kann, dass das ausgewiesene Fußballfans sind, die aber auf diese Art und Weise natürlich ein Vehikel für sich auch finden können. Das tun nicht alle, sondern der eine oder andere von denen, die ein Vehikel finden können, um natürlich ihre Gelder dann von A nach B zu bekommen mit einem Transfer oder mit einem Sponsoring oder mit einem Honorar an einen Berater, bei dem es vielleicht über das normale Bankenwesen deutlich schwieriger geworden wäre.
Ja, ich glaube, das Thema wird uns noch lange beschäftigen. Rafael, vielen, vielen Dank dir. Das Buch Football Leaks ist in der aktualisierten Taschenbuchausgabe erschienen in der Verlagsgruppe Random House, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und es gibt jetzt auch eine englischsprachige Variante davon für diejenigen von euch, die gerne die internationale Version lesen würden. Rafael, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Liebe Grüße an die Zuhörerschaft. Ich hoffe, ich konnte das ein oder andere erklären und würde mich freuen, wenn wir so verbleiben könnten.
Ja, das können wir sehr gerne so machen, dass du wiederkommst, sobald es etwas Neues gibt. Man kann dir auch auf Twitter folgen, etrafanelli, und ich bin sicher, du wirst auch dort auf die ein oder andere Nachfrage nochmal gerne eingehen, wenn jetzt dem einen oder anderen oder der eine oder anderen hier noch was gefehlt hat. Rafael, danke dir. Vielen Dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sowohl für die Unterstützung als auch für die ganzen Fragen. Das war eure Sendung heute. Es hat großen Spaß, mir gemacht, eure Fragen zu stellen. Bis bald, macht es gut, ciao. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.